which picture divides a rectangle in
half so to divide something in half we
need we need to divide it into two equal
sections so over here we've divided into
two sections but these aren't equal
these don't have the same area this part
has a much larger area than this one so
this isn't divided in half this one's
also divided into two sections but
they're not equal this one is much
bigger than this one
this is divided into equal sections but
it's not two equal sections this is
divided into three equal sections so
this isn't divided in half here we're
divided into two equal sections one two
sections and they are the same size the
same area so I'd pick that one let's
keep going this is a lot of fun which
picture divides a circle in two halves
once again two equal sections this one
this one and this one divided into three
sections and actually these these two
right over here the three sections
aren't even equal and then here this is
three equal sections but we're now that
would be thirds not halves halves would
be two equal sections so it'll be that
right over there
so which picture divides the square into
fourths or sometimes people might say
divides a square into quarters
well fourths or quarters would be four
equal sections well this is two equal
sections this is one section this is
just one hole this is two equal sections
right over here I guess you could say
this one actually is just not divided at
all this right over here is two equal
sections this is four equal sections so
this is fourths or you could say this is
divided into quarters let's keep going
let's do a few more of these which
picture divides a circle in half so this
circle isn't divided this is a circle
divided into thirds three equal sections
this is a circle divided into two pieces
but they're not equal so this isn't
divided into halves this is two equal
sections right over here so that one is
has let's do one more which picture
divides a rectangle into halves well it
has to be two equal sections this is
three equal sections this is three not
even equal sections this is
three equal sections so this would be
thirds just as this one would be thirds
this one over here is two equal sections
so that is halves